in the early days we just had one server
a very basic bit of software open source
software and a handful of us working
away on the website and I remember in
the early days you know the the number
of changes coming in where low enough
that I was able to check every change
personally as I came in that got
impossible pretty quickly as it started
to grow but now today we're up to 400
million readers every month we've got
people all around the world like 80,000
regular editors a lot more people just
you know occasionally make a change here
in there so it's quite amazing and just
back in those early days where you try
me we use the repository you and your
friends that are positive all the
knowledge it's a bit like dr. Johnson's
diary it was you know the words he knew
at the time we didn't have very much I
mean yeah and there was that it was you
know I sort of missed the days when you
could be the first person to write
Africa is a continent and hits a i
discovered Africa but we've got a bit
from there has moved on a bit yeah but
you know people often remark on and you
stayed true to the funding for me yeah I
mean you don't wanna make money out of
it you're not going to monetize it as
the word is you rely solely on donations
yeah we're a charity so charity with the
goal of a free encyclopedia for everyone
in the world in their own language and
that's always been our mission we like
our model of donations particularly
because the vast majority of money that
funds Wikipedia is from the small donors
so it really is a community-supported
project and that gives the community
lots of independence there they're not
beholden to one big donors whims or what
have you but you must have had endless
Wall Street bankers and others coming
along to use just the odd little advert
here I just think what you could make
you could be a billionaire no no one no
one's really is and of course I mean
because Wikipedia is in in the nonprofit
structure that means i don't own it it's
so charity so in some ways it's like you
know the Red Cross is really great brand
they should monetize that you know turn
it into a for-profit but it doesn't
really work what about the information
on there you sent me there's so much
either I'm a journalist we obviously use
Wikipedia quite a lot but you know we
have to treat some of the entries with a
degree of caution people get there I
mean I particularly remember when it
comes to to obituaries of people if you
know passed on and quite quickly some
rather malicious people get into those
web pages and write silly things that
they hope then get broadcast yeah yeah
exactly yeah no I think what I always
say to journalists is Wikipedia is the
best place for journalists to go to find
out the questions maybe not to find out
the answer so particularly if you go to
the discussion page is always very
interesting to read what's the Wikipedia
community puzzled about you know that
somehow this source says this but that
says the opposite let's dig around
trying to figure out okay there's your
question as a journalist like let's all
right thank you for the advice from the
man himself and what about the issue of
high-profile people self editing you
know there's this statistic I'm sure you
you're aware of in the UK that some of
British MP 650 of them one in six of
their entries have been edited from
within Parliament shouldn't be
suspicious well that's that's
interesting although sometimes I'm not
so sure it's them editing or their
opponents so we're quite sure yeah it's
something that we very much discouraged
and usually if people come in and try to
puff themselves up or whatever it
doesn't last for very long because if
they don't have good sources and so on
it's just not really the you know it's
not actually your best strategy if you
see some problem with your Wikipedia
entry or something you'd like to be
covered that isn't the best thing to do
is just send us an email I've got a
great community of volunteers who are
interested in making it right so people
will get themselves into more trouble by
you know underhanded tactics and should
well having mentioned Parliament I mean
there are things going on there and
given Wikipedia and it's an emotion of
course to freedom of speech and indeed
knowledge I'm thinking of the so-called
snoopers charter it's going through that
now the house of commons at the moment
may well become law what are your views
on things like that well you know I mean
these these kinds of things the typical
problem that we have is that the
legislators don't really understand
technology very well and so sometimes
fatal but they're scared I think they're
a bit scared of it yeah and sometimes
they pass you know laws that sound good
to them on paper but you know we know
they won't work it won't work / it puts
a lot of people's
risk and you know it's doing all kinds
of things so you know my view is that
cybersecurity is incredibly important we
need to be encouraging businesses and
everybody else to be more secure to use
encryption everywhere to save our data
from criminals and portions of
governments agree with that and then
other portions like yeah but then we
can't spy on people you know and it's
like well also the criminals can't so we
have to strike up violence there's
another another issue of course some the
Freedom of Information bill in the UK
which is obviously been around for quite
a while now they're trying or thinking
about bringing more restrictions on that
yeah I mean that's a broader issue i
think that impacts journalism it impacts
any of us who think the operations of
government should be quite transparent
obviously there's some things that are
appropriate to release right away but I
for one have a lot of concerns when I
you know when I see a politician saying
oh maybe we shouldn't be telling
everything to the public yeah well maybe
you should oh is it so I think we should
be very cautious about that and what
about we mentioned social media there
what about the increasing use of social
media we've seen it in this this country
and I'm keeping it in the politicals
yeah you know lot you know the within
the Labour Party which I know you you've
followed their the the leadership
campaign within the Labour Party people
saying well you know some MPs are
getting an awful lot of a lot of abuse
in friendly fire from within their own
party yeah yeah I mean I do think you
know one of the things that we that's
easier for us at Wikipedia is that we've
always said we're a project to build an
encyclopedia so we're not the place to
come and rent and post random opinions
not even in the discussion pages you
know if you come to a discussion page of
an MP and you just start ranting about
how much you hate them people say well
what does that got to do with improving
the article which is what we are for but
do you think you know Twitter obviously
get singled out quite a lot they've got
a very difficult problem because they
want to be a place where people can
express opinions freely and that's you
know that's a value of Twitter on the
other hand they've not been as proactive
as I think they should have been
particularly the past they seem to be
trying to shape up now about you know
really giving people the tools to deal
with I mean actual threats and abuse and
things like that it can get pretty ugly
and lastly a me do you still think much
he call been stalking about labored you
still the jeremy corbyn's bonkers you
tweeted i did in a moment of emotion i
try to stay out of politics generally
speaking i'll just put it this way i
think that the the chances of a Labour
government in the next election or as
close to zero as you can get and that's
where that's where it stands today
because of Jeremy Cove engineering
requirements leadership yeah